sometimes there is use in laying out
bombs that are going to upset people
because out of the chaos of that you can
actually build some bridges you can
actually find some people waking up hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we are talking with Dave Rubin of
the Rubin report it's an online talk
show that is extremely well regarded for
its civil tone and depth and breadth of
topics Dave Rubin thanks for talking to
Reason Nick it's good to be with you a
civil tone I'm not bringing that here no
no that that's on your show now we're
cursing and you know below the belt shot
so you posted people ranging from all
dried rocks are my low innopolis to sam
harris the the atheist anti islam
crusader and we'll talk a little bit
about him Jesse Ventura reason
contributing attitude Deirdre McCloskey
yeah the economic historian I in her
silly a lot of people a lot of different
types of people you also talked about
the regressive left a lot what do you
mean by that term the regressive left
yeah well first just on the on the guest
portion of it you know it's funny people
say oh you talk to people from all over
the political map as if that's something
so special or inventive or if we're I'm
doing something that is so wild and it's
like when did sitting down with someone
that you might disagree with become so
rare it's actually kind of said so I
cherish that I love doing that I hope in
the course of this we'll find some
things that we disagree on I think we
already have
we've had that right there but I would
say look the regressive left I I
considered myself a progressive I was I
was far on the left I worked at the
Young Turks Network they're an online
news network progressive and what I
realized is that these ideas they're all
based in collectivism basically that we
should judge as a group usually on an
immutable characteristic so we're
judging everyone on their color on their
religion on their sexuality on all of
these things and yet they're telling you
that everyone else is the bigot and the
racist and all of that stuff when really
we should all be judged as individuals
now I know you guys that reason are all
about this this is this is so obvious
that we should all be judged
as our own thoughts dictate and our
actions dictate so what I realize is
that this progressive ideology which
sounds good it sounds liberal we're
looking out for gay people we're looking
out for trans people we're looking out
for Muslim people Lisa this is not
progressive anymore it's actually
regressive because what you have to do
is throw out the minorities within the
minorities if you're judging as a group
and and sadly I think it's only gotten
worse well although I think I've moved
the dial back a little bit and got some
liberals to go wait a minute something
so something's not right here
why were you part of I mean before we
talked about how you got to leaving the
left and you have a in February you did
a piece for Prager University of video
which has been viewed over 5 million
times saying why I left to left and I
want to get to that but why were you on
the Left originally or what what where
did you start out and why were you a
progressive yeah to me look I have
sevens many times when in 1988 when
Michael Dukakis was running against
George HW Bush I was in seventh grade I
was in a mock election and I was running
Michael Dukakis his campaign and he was
a liberal and I remembered HW Bush said
to him you're he said you're a liberal
meaning this is a bad and that was like
a bad thing and then he backed off and
it was suddenly liberal was a bad word
and I'd understand that liberals were
always looking out for people liberals
cared about the other liberals cared
about poor people all of these things
and I think progressives really saw that
and and just grabbed it so for example
something like five years ago I'm
married I'm gay married I'm married to a
guy so I'm for gay marriage or
aggressives for gay divorce as well or
I'll let you know in five years you've
got to two more good years yeah I'm not
even I'm only like 10 months in right
now it's so far so good
but but basically I think progressives
grabbed all of this stuff this social
stuff and they made everyone think that
if you don't agree with them the second
day of all the things so the second day
of Allah on gay marriage if you don't
evolve the day they evolve then you're a
bigot now Barack Obama the first time
you ran for president was not for gay
marriage I suspect he was not a
homophobe at the time but right now
there are there
people out there in the country there
are Christians in the middle of our
country who I may disagree with on
virtually every political thing and
philosophical thing and religious thing
but they have personally held beliefs
that they're not forget margin I don't
want them to legislate those beliefs but
I can't expect them to evolve the second
I want them to and that that in and of
itself doesn't make them a bigot and
doesn't make them a bigot against gay
people if they say well I should be able
to marry who I want but you can't I
don't know that it makes them a bigot I
don't like that first I think in general
we use these words way too easily
everyone that we disagree with is a
racist and a homophobe an islamaphobe
and a bigot in them it's just it's just
silly it's it's lazy thinking and I
think it gets us nowhere it gets us
nowhere to have this right
so I don't think if you and your parents
and your grandparents didn't go all the
way back even if you're looking at a
religious text that I may think is
completely irrelevant and not real if
you have a personally held belief I
think you're allowed to have a
personally held belief you you just are
now if you're out there if the Mormon
Church for example which was putting a
lot of money to fight against gay
marriage right now that's a problem
because now we have a company in a
company in effect it's a religious
organization but acting as a something
to move the political dial well they're
tax-exempt now I have a problem with
that but the average person if you I
think let's put it this way I think that
for me as a gay person I can convince a
lot more people to be for gay marriage
by not screaming at them and berating
them and embarrassing them and
belittling them but by showing them that
we're all exactly the same I think you
can win a lot more people like that and
I don't even think it I know it because
of the evidence that I get from doing my
show and what people are saying to me
so you when you worked with the Young
Turks and then you had a pretty public
falling out or a big falling out with
jank you ger the kind of the head of the
Young Turks yeah they what the mullah
the Imam at the Young Turks okay yes
the Patriots Sultan the Sultan ah so
that's the word I'm looking for
yeah talk a little bit about that
because that is a I mean it's an
interesting case where he had Sam Harris
on who is a critic of
yeah and Sam Harris says that there are
certain types of that Islamic Jihad you
know the Islamic part matters and they
had a big long conversation about that
what about the tenor and tone of that
conversation turned you off and and had
you go out on your own yeah well there's
so many people that I think had their
political awakening right around when I
did and mine sparked the night that Sam
Harris was on Real Time with Bill Maher
he got into that big fight with and and
I suppose daredevil but I realize I'm in
the mid-nineteen Batman right now so he
probably preferred that too but but
basically Bill Maher who had been the
standard bearer for the left the most
you know outspoken liberal there is who
has fought against Wars who was fought
for every minority and up grow the state
and welfare and all of these things he's
been a standard bear of the left and
suddenly this guy's Sam Harris I didn't
even know who sam Harris was that's the
God's honest truth I wasn't even
following him on Twitter I did not know
who he was
here's this calm guy lays out a couple
Pew statistics talks about the
difference between the nominal Muslim
the Islamist that wants to change things
using political power versus the
jihadist who wants to use violence etc
etc the response from Ben Affleck is
you're gross and racist and then
suddenly the next day the onus was on
Bill Maher and Sam Harris to prove that
they weren't racist now forgetting that
Islam isn't a race that's another thing
that gets lost in the conversation but
my point being it exposed so many things
it exposed lazy thinking of progressives
in this case Ben Affleck where we're
trying to have a complex discussion you
immediately go to these buzz words it
shuts down the conversation but it also
showed me some other things for example
the next day all the newspapers all the
online outlets now saying is Bill Maher
racist Bill Maher I mean no one can
point to evidence of him ever being
racist and then Sam got dragged into
that then Sam sat down for a three-hour
conversation with Jake I was still
working at the Young Turks at the time
and and it was just I would welcome any
of your viewers to watch it because for
three hours Sam sits there calmly with
his leg crossed and one glass of water
and just absolutely decimates Jenkins
you know freaking out the whole time and
can't get a cogent point across if you
if you're being incredibly specific on
suicide bombers okay we had Buddha
suicide bombers kamikaze fighters okay
so we've had them all okay let's not be
so scattershot here too so I can tell
I've written and spoken about the link
between Zen Buddhism and the kamikaze
pilots right so so you can get a death
cult out of some quasi Buddhist ideas
and I've realized in the midst of that
but I thought this I don't really want
to work here and then and then a couple
months later Charlie Hebdo happened
there was a lot of pushback from various
hosts on the network about you know we
shouldn't do this yes you can do it but
you shouldn't upset people with cartoons
and then then it was just enough it was
just enough so you now tend to define
yourself as classical liberal is that
different to you than libertarian I mean
these are terms that are often used
interchangeably what goes into your
definition of a classical liberal so
this has been one of the biggest issues
that I've talked about for the last
couple of minutes first off a liberal
people don't understand this but a true
liberal really is a live-and-let-live
attitude which people prescribe usually
to libertarianism right so the only way
that I can say that there's at least in
my view a difference between a classical
liberal and a libertarianism a
libertarian is that a classical liberal
sees a little more utility for the state
and Diedre McCloskey for example add on
we discussed this but there's a I do see
some use for the state in terms of that
I don't think taxes theft automatically
and that we do need roads and I'm a
product from SUNY Binghamton so you know
cut this this interview is over I'm a
product of schools right SUNY Binghamton
and and I do believe that the state has
some use now I don't want a huge state I
firmly believe in individual liberty
more than anything else and that you
have to live the life you want for
yourself that's the best way for humans
to prosper but you're talking about it
you know a basic social safety net
national defense is a legitimate
function of government some roads courts
things like absolutely and look there
are plenty of libertarians that believe
in all of them right and that's the
interesting thing about libertarians
which I'm sure some libertarian out
there could probably sit me down long
enough and get me to say I'm a
libertarian I mean the whole point of
libertarian because it's about liberty
it's a pretty wide net that also is the
weak
of libertarianism because it's hard to
get these people to coalesce around
anything and actually make something
happen which if you look at the
Libertarian Party today I think is a
good example of that so why do you think
the left
broadly speaking or the contemporary
liberal or progressive why are they
becoming more authoritarian where
they're becoming more collectivist
because you know you're right say in the
19th century and still in Europe when
people say they're liberal they mean
more or less libertarian you know
minimal state maximum freedom what's
going on in the left that they're
becoming more authoritarian and saying
it's my way or it's our way or the
highway
yeah it is my way or the highway with
them I mean that really is what it is
and this is why we see violence at
colleges when people speak people who
you don't like interestingly you
mentioned mildly innopolis no or I at
UCLA with him we did a little talk about
a year ago and there were about five
hundred kids that were there for it
about two hundred protesters the kids
that were there were great great all
over the political math there were
liberals and leftists and Trump people
and conservatives and they were having a
great time the people that were
protesting they literally created a wall
they created a physical wall so they're
not against walls they're just against
trumped wall and they were spitting in
people's faces dumping garbage cans
getting up in cops faces and putting
cell phones just waiting for a reaction
so they can snapchat it and all that
stuff so why are they becoming less
tolerant I think it's it's a function of
the words that they use it started with
words so if everyone that is your
intellectual opponent is a racist or a
bigot or now it's a Nazi right there new
thing is now everybody's a Nazi and
you're at they're these white
supremacists coming to get all of us and
now by the way what's the new thing
after Nazi now you're allowed to punch
Nazis because you probably saw that guy
Richard Spencer get punched and suddenly
all these people on the Left were saying
yeah we should be out there punching
Nazis I mean they they think that we're
in Indiana Jones and this is 1941 and
we're fighting earlier it's just not
real but when you've pinned yourself
into an intellectual corner where
everyone against you truly is evil well
then of course the platforming is fine
and burning things down is fine and
punching people and the rest of it so
it's just an obvious extension of the
ideology that they've laid out
in the election of 2016 you you've you
flirted with Gary Johnson you where you
were a big gary johnson fan and then
yeah yeah but you ended up voting for
him right I did vote for Gary
so talk you know if we go off the campus
I wear you know students always tend to
be a little bit more extreme do you see
the same problems that you see on kind
of campuses with regret with the
regressive left is that also infecting
national politics and yeah you know so
you know are the Democrats part of the
regressive left but then are is the
Republican Party also to blame I mean
they're very extreme if you there are no
Republicans in Congress who will say I
support a woman's right to an abortion
yeah it's just not allowed so yeah talk
a little bit how this plays out in you
know national partisan politics yeah
sort of the second part of that first
it's funny people say to me you know
you're always attacking the left or
always attacking the left you must be a
conservative you must be a Republicans
no I'm not even proud to say this but
I've never voted for a Republican in my
entire life I think the last time
Giuliani ran for that third term I'm not
even sure if he was an independent at
the time or a Republican but I did vote
for him so maybe once but I've never I
voted for Obama twice I voted for Bill
Clinton so I've never even voted for a
Republican I don't defend the
Republicans they've created a huge set
of problems if they would have been
willing to negotiate with Obama over the
course of eight years we wouldn't have
seen this now reaction to them which by
the way now the Democrats are being as
intolerant as the Republicans were I
thought liberals were supposed to be
liberal meaning you were supposed to be
a little better than the worst of the
people that you're constantly railing
against the open liberal in the
Democratic Party basically doesn't exist
imagine John F Kennedy ask not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for yours which by the way as a
libertarian I find that a repulsive
thought okay fair enough yes you might
find it a repulsive thought but imagine
a Democrat saying imagine Bernie Sanders
saying that right now he would be booed
off the stage as a Democrat you're
supposed to say no we will give you this
you will get free education we will
artificially force the minimum wage to
be higher even somebody like Bill
Clinton who you said you voted for was a
free-trade Democrat they don't exist
that sure so
they've consistently gone to the left
now and there is no home for an actual
liberal and this is why I recently on my
show I found it much easier to build
bridges with guys that five years ago I
would have thought I would never talk to
so just in the last couple weeks I've
had gone back on I've had Dennis Prager
on ben shapiro these guys are staunch
conservatives and yet because we care
about liberty individual liberty even if
I disagree with them on some tax stuff
with some of them on gay marriage and
you know things that I hold very dear
and abortion and death penalty where I
disagree with all of them on all of
those things I think I can see some
bridge-building there because we're
trying to create the most opportunity
for human liberty versus where are the
bridges to build with the progressives
if they're only resolution is more state
power but not only that if they're just
gonna say that if you don't agree with
them you're a bigot a racist and I know
that sounds a little collective right if
I write them but sometimes you get
caught in we have to use labels to
describe people who were your you know
your show and you know what I mentioned
it in the intro I mean it there is a
civil tone to it and you talk to all
sorts of different people who were your
who are your idols as talk-show hosts I
mean because it is always struck me as
particularly strange that now that we
have an infinite amount of time to where
we can talk we have you know different
media different platform everything is
so super polarized and super partisan
you know so who where is this coming
from it yeah well I think for me
personally it comes from that I don't I
just truly truly don't feel the need to
be right all the time or to know
everything all the time I actually
genuinely like listening to people and I
like seeing the gears work and how do
they think and maybe you can I learned
something from everybody that I have on
sometimes I learn just that their
[ __ ] argue what what did you learn
from my love them what did I learn from
my lo what I learned from my lo is that
that sometimes there is use in laying
out bombs that are going to upset people
because out of the chaos of that you can
actually build some bridges you can
actually find some people waking up so
the best way I can lay that out is that
when I was at UCLA with Milo there were
kids coming up to me after who were
saying you know Dave I don't even really
like Milo but I found you because of him
and I like sort of the more measure
you know decent conversations so there's
you there's value in what he does
doesn't mean I agree with everything of
course I don't you know people say this
whole time I don't agree with everything
that person says as if since when was
that even a thing that you had to agree
with you know someone all the time
so I like I genuinely like talk to me
but to answer your question Johnny
Carson I mean I remember when I was in
high school and I just you know stay up
just for a little bit of the interviews
that he just seemed decent he just
seemed decent and I always liked that
and then my friend and mentor is Larry
King and I mean he's truly the king of
this and I think the best piece of
advice he ever gave me and I think I had
already incorporated this without even
knowing it is that he said to me he said
you know they when I had the show on CNN
it was called Larry King tonight and my
name was in it already so my ego had
already been stroked so how much more
did I need and I try to view it the same
way the show is called the Reuben report
they're not replacing me
you know you mean you can try Nick but
there I'll change my name it's going to
be tough it is possible I suppose but
but because of that it's like what what
would be the point of every week me
bringing on somebody so that I can
berate them or battle with them or
whatever let me you know what if you let
someone talk usually you'll find you'll
watch them put the noose around their
neck and hang themselves which I may
have done here today what you know what
do you think has to happen to make you
know kind of classical liberalism
libertarianism more popular he mentioned
a Gary and you know I I'll a Carrie
Johnson I think he he did very well not
as well as a lot of us would have hoped
good you know what has to happen for the
idea of you know freedom for me and for
you and you know people being able to
disagree but get along at the same time
what has happened for this to become the
next big kind of political or cultural
identity I think it's happening right
now I I think it's it's obvious that
it's happening right now because people
are seeing that the sides the extremes
make no sense look at the far right look
at the far left most people most
thinking people don't agree with either
of that we've been caught in it we live
in a world of Twitter where we're just
caught between everyone aiming at each
other all the time and fire
at each other all the time most people
if we can get the ideas across right we
can just use media to get the ideas of
course if I don't care what you do in
the privacy of your own home I simply
don't you could do whatever you want and
as long as it's legal whatever you're
doing and I don't know and actually if
you were doing some relief you were
smoking some illegal drugs in your house
I wouldn't care but I personally
wouldn't care about that either but I
think most people really do feel that
that it is your life to live it's your
responsibility to get something good out
of it it's you it's your responsibility
to take what's yours and not be owed
anything none of us are owed anything
and I think this idea that the left has
given us this idea of the oppression
Olympics where victimhood is the highest
virtue and you have to be more of a
victim than the next person because that
means you're higher up on their scale
and by the way what do they hold the top
of that pyramid is Islam which is the
most regressive ideology there is Islam
wherever it is this is simply the truth
I know this is that this sounds
upsetting but it is true wherever it is
it's bad for everybody including Muslims
wherever Islam has taken root it is bad
for gays for women certainly for any
religious minority and it's bad for free
thinking Muslims at the same time I will
question that I mean it's certainly the
case in in many places particularly in
the Middle East and places like Malaysia
Indonesia it's more temperate so there
are more there's more than one type of
month Islam let's well no but that's but
the people that you're talking about
that are more temperate have they've
done the work of not paying attention so
much to the ideology so the ideology
remains this is the simple fact is if we
were right now if we were in any Islamic
controlled country we would have much
different feelings about having this
conversation we would not be having this
conversation in Saudi Arabia right or in
Iran of course and that mostly that's
why I'm making a distinction between a
doctrine a set of ideas and this can't
be overstated but I know it's not
replicated all the time yeah because I'm
not talking about the average Muslim
person I judge everyone on what they say
and think and do so I don't judge
everybody on the doctrine of anything
there's plenty of stuff in the Old
Testament that's completely bananas but
unfortunately there aren't
did you walk around they believe in that
and there's actually not even that many
Christians like and there's not there's
not even that many Christians that
believe in it that doesn't mean that
there aren't plenty of Jews that I would
disagree with on some biblical stuff
obviously and Christians that I would
disagree with and analyse I said before
there's a lot of a lot of the anti-gay
marriage stuff in this country was
religiously based but the simple fact is
that where Islam has taken root it is
bad for everybody it's an ideology I
don't know that we can I don't know that
we need to defeat it but it we should be
pushing out better ideas and if liberals
were acting liberally they would realize
that this isn't the ideology that you
should be holding hands with as a final
question how do you feel about Trump
I mean you've talked a lot about him
recently on the show obviously you know
yeah surprisingly wins the election he
gets inaugurated you know what are your
fears what are your hopes for you know
the Trump Bureau yeah well first off I
wasn't surprised that he won I was on
Joe Rogan's show the day before and I
said I truly believe this is 50/50 now I
guess that's not the greatest betting
man thing ever to say but everyone was
saying this thing's over well I looked
at what Nate Silver was saying it was 90
percent and all that never then one of
your guests Scott Adams called that for
Trump you know months before so exactly
and the reason that I felt that it
wasn't in the bag was because I listened
to people I listened to Scott Adams I
listened to Mike Stern which these
people I that I disagree with on plenty
of stuff I listened to Milo and I
thought there's something happening here
there's something that the media is
missing there's an outrage that a
certain amount of people are feeling
that that is not being addressed
I think Clinton was a terrible candidate
for a series of reasons and I have you
seen the recent
a bunch of academics redid the debates
where they have I mean it's kind of
fascinating and that a lot of Hillary
supporters when they saw Trump's message
being addressed to them from a female
from a woman they were like I understand
why Trump won because they had a very
direct insistent and repeatable message
that spoke to a lot of people's anger or
sense of alienation the simple fact is
most people think politics is absolute
[ __ ] and it basically is we have
created a system where people who are
all in bed with each other who now we
know through WikiLeaks are all in bed
with the media and look how many
administration officials are married to
people that are executives at the news
networks and all the whole thing is
absurd even now this you know Trump said
he's not gonna do the White House
Correspondents Dinner the White House
Correspondents Dinner watch them for the
last eight years I'm sure you've watched
them this is they call it nerd prom
because they love thinking that they're
so nerdy to this is the worst kind of
collusion there is the people who are
supposed to be guarding the power the
Fourth Estate what do they do they're
going to dinner they're having drinks
guess what if if the president walked in
here and took a picture with us and we
could have dinner with him we might
treat him a little bit differently as as
media members but this is what we've
allowed them all to do so my fears with
Trump are look he absolutely has an
authoritarian side there is no doubt
about it
I was against executive actions when
George W Bush was doing them I didn't
like them under Obama I don't like them
now and we're seeing why they're so weak
right because all it takes is a new guy
to come in and sign something and that's
that so if you if you legislate via
executive action get ready for it to be
reversed to be executive action but by
the way where's Congress right now why
aren't these people the Republicans have
the house why aren't your maybe write a
law let the guy sign a law instead so
they're all to blame and I think until
we realize that these people are just
doing nothing that's why the answer
what's the answer
stop giving them so much power the
answer is take away the power for these
career politicians and all this money to
control us and you know who you should
control you should control you is you
and who should control me it's me
no no it's also me also yeah also you
yeah I almost put you yes which case
that well we will leave it there thank
you so much yeah my pleasure
we've been talking with Dave Rubin of
the Rubin report check out his YouTube
channel and check them out online Dave
thanks so much for talking to react
solutely for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]
you